en 46 ans de carrière jean claude
poitras a tout traversé certaines routes
cahoteuses avec des défaites des
victoires des démos main absolument
éblouissant et d'autres beaucoup plus
triste
alors donc ce mail à tous ces objets de
mémoire une fois de plus le créateur se
retrouve sur la corde raide
ils viennent compléter la direction
artistique de la première collection
d'objets de la boutique de bnq à la
grande bibliothèque et lance son tout
premier livre sur la mode au québec des
années 1950 à aujourd'hui où depuis neuf
mois
je me remets en question je doute de
tout j'ai plus de recul par rapport à ce
livre notamment et par rapport à
l'ensemble de mes collections
né en 1949 à quartier ville dans le nord
de montréal
jean claude poitras a toujours aimé la
mode mois déjà enfant j'adorais la
rentrée des classes pas parce que je
vais à l'école parce que c'était le
moment où ou ma maman et mon papa m'a
amené là il fallait que je m'habille
pour leur tour entrer dans les livres et
les jeux de fin lors c'est ce croquis
trouver dans son annuel de physique par
un professeur à la fin des années 60 qui
déclenche tout j'avais convaincu mes
parents réunion de parents de me faire
faire un test d'orientation à la ville a
quelque chose à dire on sait pas quoi
le designer en devenir complète donc des
études en dessin de mode et en graphisme
il ouvre sa première boutique en 1972 et
crée sa première collection au fil des
ans jean claude poitras créera entre
autres 90 collection prêt-à-porter pour
femmes 40 pour hommes
des robes haute couture et des
collections d'accessoires
ajoutez à cela près d'une centaine de
collections art de vivre allant de
lampes à de la porcelaine vous célébrer
la beauté au quotidien pour moi c'est sa
quête de sens et de la travers ma
vaisselle à travers peu importe parce
que je trouve que le monde a besoin de
vous il remporte de nombreuses
distinctions dont le prestigieux fil
d'or à monte carlo en 1989 remis par
karl lagerfeld de la maison chanel
mais si le prix griffe d'or décernée par
les lectrices du et le québec en 1991
qui le touche le plus cette vague
d'amour m'a littéralement porté main et
m'a réconforté dans les moments de doute
où j'ai failli tout abandonner ce désir
de tout abandonner arrive au début des
années 2000 à la suite d'une association
infructueuses avec montréal mode un
investissement de 30 millions $ de la
caisse de dépôt visant à soutenir les
créateurs québécois
le projet ne voie jamais le jour
des actions déposées en cours de part et
d'autre se solde par une entente
confidentielle à l'amiable
c'était pour moi l'échec d'un rêve
absolu je je je je sais pas comment
d'ailleurs j'ai pu trouver le courage de
me réinventer comme ça et à l'aube de
ses 70 ans jean claude poitras n'est pas
près de s'arrêter
il dessine peint enseigne le travail de
création demeure au coeur de sa vie
je vais manquer tant sûr pour tous parce
que ce que j'ai envie de faire
c'est sans fin ce que j'ai envie de
faire ce que j'ai envie de dire celui
qui dit qu'il a perdu beaucoup trop de
temps à croire qu'il n'avait rien à
apporter aux autres est maintenant en
paix avec son métier ici valérie
michaela bayne radio canada montréal